é um grande prazer estar aqui
chegou a hora da nossa cozinha
brasileira é tá dentro das festividades
e voltar a ser a realidade da cata das
pessoas mais uma pessoa é fruto da
inspiração de mulheres do lado
nordestino da minha avó mec hoje está
com 99 anos quero ver como ela está bem
embora sozinha cozinha achar que é uma
carne como ninguém faz uma troca veio
retirante do nordeste e sempre fiquei
fez questão de manter a sua identidade
ea gente sempre teve orgulho disso e eu
nunca entendi como algumas pessoas
quando iam oferecer comida pra gente de
fora mais importante mais fica
socialmente ou culturalmente oferecia
uma comida francesa italiana nada contra
me casei com francês e tenho me formei
na itália sou muito grata pela formação
mas cada eleitor por uruca cadê a nossa
muqueca e porque a gente tem que
aprender fazer outra comida se a gente
pode mostrar nossa riqueza
me sinto privilegiada porque na verdade
é a cozinha me escolheu desde pequena e
sempre soube o que eu queria trabalhar
quando vim pra são paulo vi que eu
poderia unir a paixão e profissão no
mesmo lugar que é entrou de uma causa
que a cozinha brasileira né quando
voltei da itália ouviu tanto que cada
pilar e jo conta sua história através
dos seus pratos e cozinha assim faz
parte da identidade cultural de um povo
então voltei querendo contribuir para
que através da nossa cozinha a gente
contar essa história do nosso povo ea
sua história da nossa comida ea gente
precisa definir como alimenta nossa
identidade cultural
a gente precisa a gente pode sim
valorizar o que é de fora desde que a
gente valorize primeiro o que é de
dentro né quando a gente faz isso a
gente faz uma reconexão com a terra ea
gente faz com que as nossas divisas
fiquem aqui quem se beneficia a
gastronomia pode ser um eixo de
desenvolvimento social
quem produz rapadura não quer sair da
terra
ele tem que vir uma cidade pra cidade
porque ele ainda conseguiu se manter no
campo
por exemplo no supermercado quantos
tipos de farinha de mandioca tem um
mercado normal 2
a gente tem mais de 100 tipos de farinha
de mandioca certo quantos tipos de arroz
arbóreo a gente tem no supermercado além
da vizinhança 15 pelo menos mesmo na
vizinhança
quantos azeite de dendê a gente tem de
qualidade no supermercado enquanto os
azeites normais a trave gente tem mais
de 5 qualquer supermercado chegou a hora
dos nossos produtos terem espaço nas
gôndolas dos supermercados ea gente pode
contribuir e eu vou chamar vocês pra
todos nós contribuímos é fácil todo
mundo ser em prol da cozinha brasileira
quais são os benefícios de optar uma
cozinha brasileira promove a última
popular
quando você vai para um lugar que você
faz a fala salivando que sequer um porco
no rolete você quer
a leitoa pururuca a pessoa se sente
muito lisonjeada de ti oferecer a comida
que é da terra até dez anos atrás
restaurante de alta gastronomia não
servia porco no restaurante está hoje é
coqueluche né a gente tem até japção
janaína casa do porto na verdade super
feliz que será um grande feito para a
cozinha brasileira saúde a onda da vez
as medidas incluem todo mundo agora
graças a deus as nutricionistas adotaram
a tapioca
eu como tapioca e era tida como
esquisita todos os dias o cuscuz de
milho
agora estou muito na na onda da vez
então quem busca uma alimentação sem
glúten né optem pelas coisas de farinha
de milho e farinha de mandioca fomenta a
riqueza cultural do brasil a gente
manter uma identidade própria
a gente mantém os recursos na terra há
nada contra o da aid mas porque é essas
ondas que vem apaga a nossa carne seca
né porque essas ondas que vem
apagam as nossas coisas a gente tem que
somar as coisas
a gente tem as coisas que vêm de fora e
não dar espaço para quem vem de fora e
tirar o que a gente tem aqui né
estimular a economia local eu fiz um
festival no ano passado
action festival marizabel no piauí que
tudo era o tema cozinha ep ao ensino da
região isso ganham uma força porque
mexeu com a última mexeu com um poderio
da riqueza daquela região e o mais
importante
gente eu fui na feira depois de 10 mil
pessoas terem passado e comido a comida
dos chefes locais os mercadores estavam
kindle daqui aqui porque acabou o feijão
de corda acabou
todos os produtos que eles têm muitas
vezes dificuldade de consumir né diminui
a setur-al é sustentável porque usa
menos recursos mas a riqueza no nosso
brasil é muito grande eu falo que eu vou
morrer tentando aprender tudo o que a
gente tem na cozinha brasileira e voltar
só começando
ab e como vocês podem incentivar a
cozinha brasileira então a primeira
coisa quebrou o preconceito de comida
brasileira é pesada
apesar da mão de quem cozinha comida
brasileira é feia não é colorida e feia
mão de quem coloca na mesa tem uma
legião de restaurantes que estão
dedicados à cozinha brasileira mas ainda
o público acha caro a comida brasileira
e não acha caro quando vai comer comida
francesa comida brasileira que não é
saudável é supersaudável maxixe eo
pepino brasileiro tudo que você faz com
pepino japonês se pode fazer com maxixe
aponta do maxixe é deliciosa e para
fazer com um hambúrguer é delicioso
também e aí qualquer sugestão selecionar
produtos brasileiros incluir os na sua
lista de compra do lado da cno a coloca
a canjiquinha porque falo a gente não
coloca porque ninguém compra mas aí
vocês vão contribuir começar a comprar
nossa gente
selecione cursos e livros sobre o
assunto porque ainda assim os cursos
onde risoto de massa tem mais público do
que os cursos de como fazer sua própria
carne seca o curso como fazer essa
farofa
selecione os cursos e privilegia os
cursos que são de cozinha brasileira
vocês vão se surpreender pelo menos um
dia eu não tô pedindo todos os dias um
dia da semana que seja domingo que é
celebrar que seja um prato brasileiro
então se vocês mostrarem que vocês têm
interesse por nós que estamos lutando
por essa causa social que a
transformação através da cozinha
todo mundo está contribuindo priorizar
em datas celebrativas a nossa cozinha
nada melhor do que pegar uma uma boa
parcela de barro das goiabeiras e fazer
uma moqueca deliciosa farofa de dendê e
arroz de coco para fazer um almoço de
domingo eleger um ingrediente
desconhecido por semana para conhecer um
pouco mais porque eu começo a achar
estranho quando o exótico é o que é
brasileiro gente de repente o tucupi
exótica que não há não é estranho ele
pode ser regional mas por agentes e
brasileiro a gente não deveria chamar de
exótico um produto que é nossa que
deveria ter vergonha de não conhecer o
nosso brasil
a pessoa come cabrito mas não como bode
é o mesmo animal tá
adoro cabrito armas bode não como é
então vamos quebrar o preconceito
eu sempre fiz questão no brasil a gosto
de manter o nome original porque eu não
tenho vergonha da identidade não tem
vergonha do meu sotaque net lapa não é
sam pitta é tilápia em vários lugares
essa pitta é porque a gente a tilápia
tanta coisa que a gente precisa incluir
mais no nosso cotidiano caipirinha né
gente
então assim eu gostaria de finalizar e
falar que eu gostaria que a gente
fizesse todas as vezes que vocês
comprarem produtos brasileiros que vocês
fizerem seus pratos brasileiros que
vocês fizerem os seus cursos ou
comprarem livros que é o nosso movimento
agora
a gente tira uma foto e fesh fesh tag
pela cozinha brasileira
todos nós podemos contribuir todos nós e
quem ganha somos todos nós
muito obrigada rio